your first big job in Show Business the
genius Paul Winchell who was a
ventriloquist he hired you how you know
all this I know about you you're amazing
he hired you to be the girlfriend of
Knucklehead SMF of the dummies the
dummies and the first one I sang
Somewhere Over the Rainbow I called
Nanny to tell her I was going to
beforehand right that I was going to be
on the Paul winshill show and she said
well say hello to me and I said I said I
can't say hi
nanny in right so that's when we worked
out pulling my ear so isn't that
difficult when you're imagine you're
nervous in those early years on TV and
you're on live television I assume it
was live and you have to work in pulling
your ear to say hi to your grandmother
well I figured I would because if I
didn't I'd get hell right she would say
why didn't you pull your ear for me you
know but I always did I did it at right
at the end of the show so that was no
problem